what's up ladies and gentlemen in this
video I want to talk about John Snow and
which weapon he will use when he finally
faces off against the night king and his
army as we all know the night king has
been the most dangerous threat to
humanity in this world ever since season
1 episode 1 we have been aware of this
threat beyond the wall and now that the
series is getting closer and closer to
its end I think most of us feel that
this wall will come down leaving
Westeros completely vulnerable against a
devastating attack from the night king
luckily for Westeros Jon Snow is well
aware of this threat and I believe he
will do everything in his power to stop
it we know what we need to kill the
white and we also know what we need to
kill the White Walkers but we can't
guarantee what can kill the night king
considering he is the most powerful of
the others it's probably going to take
some pretty magical [ __ ] to stop him
it's just a matter of time before the
humans face off against the others and I
am confident Jon Snow can lead this
attack with the help of Daenerys and her
dragons but if there ever comes a time
to where someone has to face the night
king himself I think that person would
be Jon Snow ever since they had that
epic stare down at hardhome I've always
felt that these two would meet again on
the battlefield and if this is the case
will Jon sword be enough to stop the
night King John Snow currently carries a
Valyrian steel sword Longclaw
which was the ancestral weapon of house
Mormont for over five centuries most of
you know this was the sword that Giora
Mormont gave to his son Jorah Mormont
when he decided to take the black and
join the Nights Watch but Jorah Mormont
[ __ ] up after he tried to sell
poachers in the slavery to make some
extra cash for his lady Ned Stark was
set to execute Jorah Mormont
but Jorah went into exile but before he
hightailed it out of Westeros he did
leave the sword behind
that's when G or sister returned the
sword to the wall if you fast forward
some time later Jon Snow joins the
Nights Watch then Lord Commander Mormont
gets attacked in his chambers by a white
in which John Snow saved his life by
burning that way but what they don't
tell us in the show is when Jon Snow set
fire to the white it actually caused a
fire that damaged Longclaw
since it's made of Valyrian steel it
didn't do too much to the blade but it
actually burns the original hilt that
had a barrel in it that's when Lord
Commander Mormont decided that since it
needed to be fixed anyway he might as
well stick a wolf's head on the hill
then get the sword to Jon Snow for
saving his life and this is the sword
that Jon has been carrying ever since
it's actually the only sword to ever
kill a white Walker we've seen Sam and
Mira kill a white Walker but that was
with dragonglass so as of right now Jon
has the only sword thus far to stop a
walker but there are other Valyrian
steel swords in this story plus there is
another magical sword out there that we
have seen before at the Tower of joy
does anyone think Jon will keep Longclaw
at his side for the duration of this
series or will he end up using something
else when the White Walkers come
marching and sweeping through Westeros
one of the most popular theories out
there is that Jon Snow is azor Ahai
reborn
missoura hai was a legendary hero who
wielded a burning sword called light
bringer could John be the reincarnation
of this legendary figure who was chosen
once before when the darkness laid over
the world it is said that this will
occur after a long summer when an evil
when cold darkness descends upon the
world this is when a Zora high will
stand against the others with light
bringer once again if Jon Snow ends up
being this hero will Longclaw be his
light bringer the story of light bringer
is shrouded in mystery as well
when azor Ahai needed to forge a sword
to fight this darkness it was said that
he labored for thirty days and 30 nights
until it was done but when he went to
temperate in water the sword broke the
second time he spent 50 days and 50
nights to make the sword even better
than the first time then he captured a
lion and drove the sword into its heart
but once again that steel shattered then
finally he worked for a hundred days and
a hundred nights busting his ass trying
to make this sword this time he called
for his wife Nissa Nissa
and he asked her to bare her breasts he
then drove the sword into her living
heart her soul combining with the steel
of a sword creating Lightbringer the red
sword of Heroes
if Jon Snow is azor Ahai reborn and he
needs to forge a new sword to go against
the others will he need to do the same
thing in order to create it when it says
light bringer was first tempered in
water could that mean a Greyjoy then
when it was plunged into a lion's heart
does that mean a Lannister with Jon Snow
need to do these things as well who will
be his Nissa Nissa if this were to come
true personally I don't know I think
Longclaw will be Jon sword in the end I
love Longclaw it's one of my favorite
looking swords in the show but it is a
bastard sword which makes perfect sense
why Jon would end up with that sword but
I think there will come a time when we
find out Jon Snow is not a bastard but
instead a legitimate Targaryen and in
that case Jon will no longer be carrying
a bastard sword I would not be surprised
to see Jon give Longclaw back to the
Mormons whether that be back to Jorah or
given to leona that is up for debate
Liyana does deserve to have the sword
back in her family for all that she has
done but perhaps when Jorah comes back
into the fold and he goes up north with
Jon maybe Jorah does something that
makes Jon once you return it to the
family Jorah could potentially save
Jon's life at some point and I know
there are people out there who think Jon
will end up with Hart's Bane which was
the Valyrian steel sword that Samwell
Tarly took from his father when he left
for the Citadel Hart's bane is the
ancestral Valyrian steel sword of house
Tarly the tarly's have had this sword
and their family for over 500 years as
well and at first some people refer to
the name Hart's Bane as a metaphor for
Lightbringer the sword that ends up
piercing the heart of a nice Anisa like
person we know Sam now has this sword
with him and we also know from spoilers
that at some point Sam will make his way
back to Winterfell next season if Jon
knows Sam has this sword just laying
around Jon could end up with this sword
if he does in fact give Longclaw
back to the Mormons I've seen people say
Longclaw already has a wolf on its hilt
though but that doesn't mean anything
because that hilt can easily be changed
once again there is another Valyrian
steel sword up north as well which is
Oathkeeper the Valyrian steel sword that
Brienne has been carrying around
that was given to her by Jaime Lannister
Oathkeeper was once the Starks ancestral
sword ice that Tywin Lannister had
melted down in reforged into two new
Valyrian steel swords for Jaime and
Joffrey wouldn't it be kind of poetic if
Jon Snow ended up with one of these
swords that was once in his family for
hundreds of years
I wouldn't be surprised to see that
steel end up in the hands of the Starks
once again but there is another sword
that came into play at the same time we
learned that jon snow had Targaryen in
his blood and that sword is dawn dawn is
the ancestral sword of house Dayne this
was the sword Sir Arthur Dayne was
carrying when he was left to guard the
Tower of joy in which Lyanna stark was
inside giving birth to Rhaegar Targaryen
son Jon Snow in the Song of Ice and Fire
novels dawn was forged from the mettle
of a fallen star most likely some kind
of meteorite its blade is said to be as
pale as milk glass which is also said to
be just as sharp as Valyrian steel now I
think it's interesting that the blade is
said to be as pale as milk glass could
that be in reference to another type of
dragon glass but something even more
powerful or magical there are numerous
people in this community that think this
sword could be down in Winterfell
scripts just waiting for Jon Snow to
find it in wield it the story says that
Ned Stark returned it to house Dayne but
we do not know if the television show
will take the same route nor do we know
if meta actually did return the sword
this would also be another poetic ending
if Jon Snow ended up using this sword to
fight the others the same sword that was
used to protect him and his mother at
the Tower of joy if this sword is in
fact made out of something from a
meteorite it does sound like it could be
magical enough to defeat the night king
but what does everyone else think about
these possibilities I wanted to make
this video because I'm very curious to
see what this section of the community
thinks about Jon Snow using another
sword when it comes time to fight
against the night king and his army
comment below and give me your opinion
on this do you think Jon will continue
to use Longclaw for the remainder of the
series or do you think he will wind up
with Hart's Bane or dawn or one of the
swords that was once the Starks
ancestral family sword ice let me know
what you think down below before I go I
want to thank every
one that has shown their support on
patreon I will be releasing a video over
there within the next few days
Thank You daughter of Ice and Fire bran
the Builder cows [ __ ] chickens
Nichkhun Ella Jean USMC Sir Thomas
IndyCar podcast cypher solar James
Millar a dawn of Ice and Fire
Kari Neves marine and the Theon defense
squad thank you all so much I will see
you down in the comment section bye